i think we're good to go
honestly it's kind of surreal you guys i
i can you believe it's been 20.
i think we're good to go
honestly it's kind of surreal you guys i
i can you believe it's been 20
angel gizman is first kerdiman sharma
very close second infinity shades how is
it going hello everybody what is up
welcome back another week
another marvel disney plus series
this episode i think is going to be let
me mute this
very close
i think this week's episode is going to
be
particularly a very cool one
the the doctor strange one uh
where he doesn't lose his hands he loses
the love of his life
oh crap well that's in the trailer today
that was in the trailer today i think
most people probably saw it
what's up everybody let's go
[Music]
evarax ran
woof said her son
how's it going oh i got to go to school
tristan dang
that's all right the the episode will be
here
be there waiting for you
oh thanks king of ink i appreciate that
on skeletal one to ten how hype are you
for spider-man now at home matthew
sanchez yeah that's gotta be like a 50
or something like
especially because like
like basically like all the leaks i've
been talking about a lot of them were
confirmed hey what's up mal shepard
a lot of them were confirmed in you know
with the trailer um a good amount of
them were confirmed which makes it more
exciting for me and even if like
theories and and leaks and stuff like
that don't end up becoming true like i'm
still okay with that because
i was shocked right because that because
then you know i'm i'm shocked after that
i don't uh
then i didn't know everything it's kind
of cool when all the links are true and
it's like no i knew it like all the
links are true it's like another level
of excitement
but
even
even with
it not being true i'm still like okay
like well they weren't true but i really
liked what happened yes yes yes yes yes
yes
in two days max conrad yes i'm going to
see it thursday at i believe like 6 30
is my time
uh that'll be my third time watching it
and i'm so excited for it i'm like just
so excited to see shangchi again uh hey
thanks ayden i really appreciate that
uh
small giant
give my opinion on chongqi
uh
top five favorite marvel movies
for me now
um
it
in no particular order because i can't i
can't really order them avengers
avengers infinity war avengers in game
thor ragnarok
shang ching the legend of the tin rings
like i loved the movie i really did
oh infinity shades thanks super chat but
i feel for you uh did you say you were
in
australia is that is that where you said
you were i'm sorry if i don't remember
correctly
uh car chef amp how's it going coming
back care chef amp sorry if i'm not
pronouncing that right did you hear
michaela cole is playing anika
normalizing black panther what kind of
forever
um i had not heard that but that is good
news i appreciate you telling me that
uh how old am i jj i am almost 32 um
october is my birthday so i'm 31
i'm about to be 32 i'm an old guy
uh
daily beagle daily what if spider-man
wasn't a menace
uh
you're thinking the fast man's have died
in avengers you guys making you move
with a new hero to the fast man like
spider-man the fast man
batman and daredevil best duo i you know
batman's actually my favorite uh
superhero
actually um
yeah
so
heck yeah
uh yes i have i have seen
all the promos
and i i would i will say yeah they're
they're kind of starting to show a lot
you know what i'm sorry guys i didn't
even check my audio are we doing okay
i didn't even see if it was
uh yes
okay we're good am i six five nashton no
flip it around almost i'm five eight on
a good day
five five seven i would say five seven
and a half
five seven and a half i'm uh
i'm kind of short
yeah no i don't think john cena is
sandman loki i think it's the original
actor who plays it
yeah geo multiverse madness is going to
be epic i cannot wait for that movie um
but part one
is
spider-man right
all right let me make sure everything's
running
running well here looks like we're doing
okay
yeah everything's oh i need to do one
thing do it over sure
this is such a weird thing something mr
anderson's in the house i was just
wondering about you man what's up
i just blocked on youtube and there's a
video by good morning america that says
spider-man breaks the web
and it's
i think it's like the trailer
which is funny
clever clever thanks toasty trigger
appreciate that dr string's become
source of supreme i'm thinking
i i think
after multiverse of madness maybe i
think that'll be like his test
um
and if you're thinking like oh you know
it'll um
it'll happen in this what f episode
that's obviously completely different
and maybe but i uh i know the whole deal
is gonna be
um
i think i think the title of today's
episode
is what if
the sorcerer supreme or what if doctor
strange lost the love of his life is
that
i think that might be be the title of it
uh so yeah yeah oh let me go back here i
see the super chat i see it and i'm
coming to it i'm sorry let me get back
on the right screen here
skill be snacks scooby's next i'm so
sorry if i
i
i'm not sure how to pronounce that but
thank you for that super chat i greatly
appreciate it greatly greatly appreciate
it
um any future interviews uh well
hopefully i'm getting some
for the eternals um
disney seems to like me
uh despite leaking some things that
apparently i wasn't supposed to i got a
little worried about that
but they were very nice about it and
since it's kind of sony as well they
kind of didn't occur
so
that was a funny conversation to have
and i'm just kind of like
oops but at the same time i'm like okay
so
you just confirmed it
[Laughter]
so yeah um
kenzie z07 uk
what am i most excited for no way home
and you love channel thank you so much
really really appreciate that um
i think just the the three spider-man
together
like honestly
i wouldn't even care if it was like five
seconds of them
in like a weird multi-dimensional portal
and then they separate i just want to
see all well i want to see all of them
interact i think that's my tobey maguire
is my spider-man i was like
11 years old when i saw the first
spider-man or maybe that was the x-men i
can't remember how old exactly it was
but i was like 14
no i was younger than that i i might
have been like eight or nine years old
when i saw the first spider man
wow i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
think about that i'm gonna have to think
about that but toby is my spider-man
like i i love him
um
and i'm about to re-watch all the movies
which i'm really excited maybe i'll do
watch party like re-watching all the old
movies maybe we can all do that together
let's
i missed the super chat where did it go
and it was from infinity stage yeah
australia okay good i thought i remember
that right
you can see the resemblance in the green
goblin to the joker they're both just
evil and are very psychological in the
things they do
they also try and get the hero to kill
that's true yeah we were talking about
that last time huh hey look it's kyrie
kyrie that's my cat you can barely see
her because all the lights on me right
now
but i have two cats too
rocket
who i did name after rocker raccoon
is sleeping on my tva jacket right here
i don't know how she got that on the
floor
uh
yeah let's see let's see
uh
i don't know what your oops was for mr
anderson do i need to oh the for the for
the leaks yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
a couple pictures that uh i shouldn't
have shown
but i didn't know they were
i like when i talked about the pictures
i thought
like i didn't know if they were real and
i thought they obviously they could be
but people are so dang good at photoshop
now
turns out they were real
um i'm actually doing a video on that
tomorrow i already recorded the video
it's a funny video it's a it's a quick
like four minute video in spider-man a
couple leaks one really really funny
thing
so keep an eye out that's gonna come out
in the morning it might breakdown for
episode three four
should go out in the afternoon sometimes
abhishek
chuck rubberty what's your take on the
new titles by marvel
do you mean movies or do you mean
literal titles i will answer both
regardless because you you did a super
chat for it um
the movies i really really love
um
i'm very very excited for all the movies
they're doing a lot of disney plus shows
which i'm super pumped about but
obviously when you have so much of that
you're more excited for others than some
um
but i think
i think they're all good i think you
have a mix of
i think you have a mix of
returning people wanda hawkeye doctor
strange spider-man and a good mix of new
people like guys i i i genuinely mean
this i'm not like trying to say this for
disney or anything like that or marvel i
genuinely love shang chi
it's one of my favorite marvel movies
now
it's one of my favorite marvel movies
and
i i loved it so if they're and i think
eternals is going to be crazy good as
well so if
this is direction
if this is the direction that marvel is
going
yeah i'm i i am liking the new titles
uh i'm not married no
do you think we will see more obscure
mutants come to the mcu
to start because of deadpool and what
that did uh yes
but
not necessarily because of deadpool but
because
of what i think marvel wants to do to
kind of differentiate themselves
differentiate the mutants um yeah
nice shianchi poster
on bag or bag it's actually
it's actually the bag that they gave us
at the premiere they gave you like a
goodie bag after you can see right here
is my uh my badge
that said guest on it
um
yeah i loved it
it was really good uh
a shot thank you for that super chat i
really appreciate that um
the mandalorian hi
how's it going
uh good to see you too wood on
did i hear about the bruce banner the
rumors about bruce banner appearing in
moonlight chiffon sayad ali
i did
um
and yeah he kind of basically admitted
to that didn't he um
sebastian alcantar when does shangchi
take place in the mcu sixth month six
months after
yeah
um
chances wand is controlling doctor
strange in the way home he is super sus
huh
now
maybe actually if wanda wants to break
open the multiverse somehow to kind of
find her kids
you know like where are my kids at i
need to i don't know how to break open
the multiverse but this doctor strange
guy does you know maybe i actually
really like that theory
uh but i i asked the source
who typically knows a lot
um
and i said hey what's the deal with
doctor strange is he mephisto
is something going on you know i had to
ask if it was mephisto
and he said no it's dr strange to to to
his knowledge
granted he probably doesn't know
everything but i mean he
he tells he knows a lot hey turtle games
i
love having you in these parties thank
you so much uh
crane69 i believe
it will be the best i uh
yeah hey mayank michelle his first time
going to cinema after far from home dang
well i'm super excited for you
i'm super super excited for you
um kyle mclelland
let's do i have an idea why doctor
strange didn't know more about the
multiverse before
he did what he did with peter parker in
the trailer
um well i think he kind of explained it
because he said like
the amount we know
about the merc
multiverse is what did he say
frighteningly
little
so i don't know if it's like
specifically him
rather than
humans
haven't figured it out
um
you know
like i'm not i'm not even sure like the
ancient one maybe figured it all out
right
um
but i think that's gonna be revealed
i've seen a lot of leaks for doctor
strange too kratos um
one i know is true out there but there's
there's a there's a lot up there and
here's the thing with plot leaks like
like
really typically there's something true
in each of them
i've been doing this for
since
2018 i've been doing this for three
three and a half three years three and a
half years now
and
the amount of plot lakes i've seen
and have looked back on because i did it
with like avengers in game i looked back
on everything that i heard about it and
and typically
there's something true about each plot
leak in there right um
because i think what typically happens
is um
if somebody finds out something real
and two things happen they either just
make something up around it because they
can
or they want to put out the real thing
but don't want to get caught and make up
something fake around and blah blah blah
now some of them are you know insanely
cool
or insanely accurate
infinity shades again what is up thank
you for the super chats have i heard of
sideshow collectibles or hot toys they
have some amazing marvel figures that
look like they came right out of the
screen yeah they're insane actually i
think was it hot toys that just
released one for shanxi
that is like
insane yeah uh
yeah i i think they're cool um
i actually have some but they're still
wrapped up from my move i gotta get them
and like put them on here and stuff
um geo
1987 wolf i'll give you another woof
there
uh or to end do you think galactus will
be referenced in eternals um
i hope so
there's ways to connect it with the
eternals especially like with the
celestials and all
the question is
is galactus coming
in this saga
um
if it's building up the secret wars
there's a lot of other villains that it
could be and i feel like galactus needs
to be larger than life
he can't be
he can't be like
uh like ultron was you know what i mean
like
he needs to be so big
he needs to be a thanos
um
and he needs to be kind of bigger than
thanos because he is bigger than thanos
so
i don't know when he's coming i haven't
heard anything about him coming now
there is i want
this is going to be hard to word
there is something that would lead me to
believe that he could be coming um
and i think you all
you'll find that in a future project um
i can't really tell you any more than
that
uh damian warner sure yeah that's a
great that's a great uh question or
request could you take a minute to
explain some of the upcoming marvel
movies
that some of us might not know about
moon knight secret wars edc
brother um
so uh we'll just talk about all projects
because secret wars oh wait no secret
wars did you see secret wars or see
yeah yeah so moon knight um
moon knight's a very interesting
character
uh and from what i've been told from
what i've what i've heard
um
they are going to deal with the mental
uh
mental problems that he's going to have
so
basically the character
doesn't know
if he is an actual
like god that like an ancient egyptian
god is possessed or if he's crazy and
he's a little bit of both um so he
fights with mental illness and he
doesn't really know like reality
or like this like dream state or
something like that so he doesn't really
know and he has a lot of different uh
alter egos uh identities i don't know
the correct term
for it for them
uh he's got like multiple personality
disorders right so one of them is like
this rich billionaire person one of them
is this guy who like fights people on
the street um
so you know
that's going to be cool to see too so
it's like really it's a very interesting
character it's very rough character
um
and and the fact that they are going to
explore like this mental illness part of
it
is pretty cool because it is kind of
cool to see this guy kind of like
you know am i like
am i really like the what's it called uh
like the vessel of like this this
ancient egyptian gods power or am i
crazy right
i i don't know
that that's kind of the cool thing about
it uh real quick marina thank you so
much for that super chat
love my shank tea review marvel loves my
[ __ ] review they're quoting me in the
latest trailers uh loving all the
spidels thank you so much marina thank
you so much for commenting uh thank you
so much for always joining here in the
super chats really really appreciate you
uh and yeah that's it's like a dream
come true like really um
since i was a kid
uh i've just like i i'll post a photo
like my twitter or my instagram uh
sometime
of me is like i'm like
four or three i don't know as well
dressed up as wolverine
and um
i don't know this has been my dream for
like a really long time
and it's very surreal
that it's
that it's kind of happened my dream
obviously is to be an mcu movie but this
is it for me like this has been this has
been amazing so uh it's been
it's been crazy thank you very much
shiffan sayad have i watched free guy
yeah i did i watched it before it came
out because
disney owns
20th century
so disney sent disney hooked me up with
a pre-screening like two weeks before
loved it so
great
so this is great uh but getting back to
[Music]
damien warner so secret wars there's
there's two cigarette war stories
and if you've heard the ones that i've
talked about in my videos i always talk
about what's known as battle world
and i'll explain this in a way that i
think correlates to the mcu
basically the multiverse is like
starting to shatter each like pocket
universe they're all
basically like
shattering um and they're like kind of
getting destroyed so what happens is
like all of them basically merge into
one and everybody ends up on one world
which is known as battle world uh now
there's a lot of different aspects to
battle world it's a really huge sword i
really recommend reading secret wars
battle world uh the story because
because it's it's it's phenomenal uh
it's crazy good
but um
you know that's where you get god
emperor doom
and uh
the beyonder
and it's where he pretty much makes
everybody fight
and all the the multiverse like when
they clash all these different universes
when they clash together it's like
that's when you get multiple
different variations of the same
character or variance right
so
in our case for the mcu
we would have like multiple chongqi's
maybe multiple eternals like of the same
people right um
who's going gonna be around multiple
look we already have multiple loki's
right um
i'm trying to think of the heroes
multiple falcons winter soldiers uh
who's gonna be around kate kate bishop
captain marvel thor
and
essentially
they all fight together to
kind of save
well themselves and then you know you
somehow find a way to restore the
multiverse so
uh if i could play any future marvel
character in the movies who would you
play and why
i mean i've
tweeted
uh several times
wanting to be wolverine
i'm short i can get really really mad
and i can get in really really good
shape
obviously to play play the role um like
if you told me i had a chance to play
that
i'd start taking steroids and i'm just
kidding but no like uh i mean
that would be a cool character to play
i i think i would do
i think i would
do well playing that character um
but like what i love to play freaking
magneto yeah
like
or doom yeah
don't know if i could pull those
characters off would i want to yes
could i pull wolverine off yes i i
believe i could pull wolverine off not
sure i could pull doom off and uh
magneto off but i would love to play
those thanks for asking that thanks
again for another super chat um
does the tin rings connect to spiderman
no way home has spider-man's magical
suits and they look very similar
i lost it it's gone i think he said they
look very similar to win woos
what marvel character is my crush that's
gotta be wanda i mean
or uh haley atwell agent carter
but i think probably wonder um
and no not to my knowledge it doesn't
connect to
chongchi and spiderman don't connect not
to my knowledge there are some
connections which you'll see uh they're
very subtle they're very good at doing
it
daniel thank you super chat do you think
spider-man will make an appearance
in no way
home
yes
it's his movie
unless you're talking about the other
ones um then yes
i do i do i do we do um and thanks for
the super chat
i don't know which particular spider-man
you're talking about but i think we're
going to see the trio toby andrew and
tom holland
there's been
not i don't want to say rumors theories
of miles
and i'll be doing a video about that
soon because i actually actually report
that i'm actually
really curious in that
like
yeah
i
i would love to see miles i question
a question
if it's the right time
mayhem does she relate to 10 rings in
iron man 3. they they do reference that
yes
geo what do i think about billy and
tommy multiverse madness i think that's
going to be wanda's
driving factor
um i think they're going to play a big
part for wanda apparently the episode's
out and i'm
i'm excited for this one uh
i think it's gonna be very different
the episode is out
mr anderson
greg alba
here we go
it's gonna tweet back at greg alba he
called me i missed it then i called him
back but he says i didn't call him back
but i did
uh
willie x i'm not sure what edit you were
talking about uh if it's the one on
twitter i think i did and i think i i
commented on it
yeah i saw that kratos it's funny huh
we're just in the beginning here give me
a little
bigger than that there we go
i need to turn the captions on so i can
catch
little little things
where are the subtitles
what if
how do i get away
by the way there we go
right right right
just
looks like a
a ferrari or a lamborghini for doctor
strange
look at him all dapper is he waiting for
oh look who it is
is that supposed to be
it is christine
wow that voice actress isn't even close
to
i don't rachel mcadams yeah
so they're just talking they're just the
car not talking
what time is in the united states twelve
fifty four
oh
oh and there it is
oh
he actually saved it
until they got hit from behind
hey rocket
oh it's falling into the water too
i haven't seen doctor strange in a bit
did the car fall into the water when
okay so this is way different his hands
obviously didn't get
she he didn't lose his hands
but he lost his heart so that's
that's the difference here
so that okay so he sought answers across
the world world and in the mystic arts
okay
oh manipulation and alteration of time
lines
she's alive
oh
ancient one
oh look at that and fought or mammo
oh he became the sorcerer supreme he
said it
they haven't actually ever called them
the sorcerer supreme in the mcu yet he
said he's the master of the mystic arts
oh he can't let go of his love which i
understand
uh
winded noise oh that's probably my fan
sorry about that
he wants to go back in time
join me before you do something reckless
hey mark thomas rosario how's it going
he's totally wants to go back in time to
try and save christine
and he did
he went back in time
interesting okay
so he went back in time using the time
stone
okay
you're being delightful that's cute
he still got hit
and he still fell
interesting
oh so he's gonna reverse it again
and he's going to try to change it again
he's stuck in that time loop essentially
again
taking a different route now
oh nope
wow
all right so he can't save her
this is kind of like a this is like a
fate thing
do they make it
oh my gosh then she has a heart attack
what
she just keeps dying so no matter what
he does he can't change the fact that
she dies
doesn't pick
of course
wow
oh
does that change things
then here comes the car
dang this is like
i hate this i mean i like it because i
like i like the story but wow
wow thanks muhammad appreciate that wow
this is crazy thanks mfp
so no matter what
he can't save her
guys i'm not talking about miners or
some spoilers in here so i
if you guys don't want spoilers
excuse me i wouldn't
why are you here
she has to i get it
she has to die
because he has to seek the mystic arch
wow
her death is an absolute
point in time that's big i'm gonna write
that down
absolute point in time
you cannot reverse an absolute point wow
i like this
i alright rozzy yeah
oh this path only leads to the end of
this reality
i'll be forced to stop you this gets
insane
you'd have to find me first
oh he did it he got away
oh
oh
hi
this is a 35 minute episode
i'm liking
no she didn't die in a doctor strange
movie that's why this is the alternate
timeline like what if
he didn't lose his hands or his fingers
right
what if he lost the love of his life
interesting
interesting
oh i'm really liking this
oh
look the strangest dress sorcerer i've
ever seen that's pretty good
it's harmony
cagliostro
oh bang
sorcerer armani that's great
uh i'm at 13 52 right now that's where
we're at
oh that's purdy oh we thought that was
like a one condom scene or something
like that
oh
okay
how long will you be staying here as
long as it takes
oh we getting all the books
how do you read them all
time manipulation
what up
and nigh impossible to attend
gain the power through the absorption of
other beans oh he's gonna like he's
gonna become evil
is that shoe mcgorth
sure does look like it
i need to borrow your powers
oh i mean it has to be shea mcgorth
right
these episodes are starting to connect i
think because i think this is the same
one that peggy carter fought in the
first episode
mystic beans do not bargain it has to be
shumagorth
he knows
yeah it's canon it's just not sure we're
just not sure how it's gonna tie in
love can break more than your heart it
can shatter your mind
ain't that the truth
keeps calling him our money i love that
maybe a banks
if they won't surrender their power i'll
take it oh if it's about to get intense
so who are you going to take it from at
first
oh
unknown
oh
what the freak
what
oh
okay
he just
he just got the cloak levitation okay
whoa that's intense oh geez
dude this is sick
more who you got next oh that's dope
i wonder if that's fing fang boom
whoa
is that thor's horses his thing dude
this is a
watch her i could warn him i could
intervene
i like that
interfere watch her interfere
oh he sensed his presence
watch out watcher he might take your
power
oh snap look at that
oh my gosh
time to meet an old friend you're going
to fight shoot you're going to take the
powers of schumacher
oh look at that
take the power take the power
oh
[Music]
all right this this this episode's
pretty good
don't
don't take his powers
sorcerer money
did he just basically say that doctor
strange has been there for centuries
maybe the other strange will
other strange
you're only half a man
what
he wasn't the only doctor strange in
this universe
interesting
what does he do
i'm okay okay i'm in it i'm in it
the whole world seems to be getting
eaten by darkness
oh that's creepy if i
wow okay
ancient one
what is the ancient one
what is happening
foreign
you are
i knew it
interesting
two timelines in one universe
i have an evil twin
more like misguided
oh yeah he can't save her if he saves
her the universe will be destroyed
you
doctor strange
only strange can fight himself
okay
no
the very least to save you
the guardian vicente
he's found me
that's not good nope
good luck
dang i like this episode here he is
what happens if he steps out of it
no he can't step out of it because he's
lighter
yes rozzy better oh
yeah that's all the doctor strangers and
one strange supreme
dude
um
someone's powerful now
i spent centuries wow
he needs him
we can
i think it is like a mini version of
multiverse of
madness destroy the world
deranged
your marbles are long gone
oh
oh snap
what do we got going on
i like this
you need to let go
thanks jio
he doesn't like dracula
oh no the tva is here
oh that's so cool it's like freaking
wonder woman there
oh that's pretty cool
oh he got him
oh he sent the cloak of he's in the
cloak at him
ha that's dope
the cloaks are fighting that's super
cool
oh the spell is wearing off
ha ha
oh the good good thing for the cloak oh
no he broke it
strange got his cloak back
oh
little ball of light
whoa
oof
where is he at
interesting
oof
he's remembering everybody die
oh he can't do it
you're not her
oh
yes son of a
he's oh he punched the spell off him
oh no it's still on him kind of
there's an offer now it looks like it's
up no almost off him
oh it's about to happen
oh he's absorbing him
but maybe that was his plan
and here he goes
oh snap
oh oh
snap what the heck is happening
yes
this is a nightmare well because he
looks like a beast
i can fix this
oh
what you gonna do
i'm gonna do that
oof
noise talking to the watcher
you were warned
the watcher he has to interfere
not a god neither are you
he can't interfere oh
oh so did i wonder if this universe just
gets destroyed
interesting
dang
oh
holy crap
oh my gosh it got destroyed
okay this turned me on what if i was not
really into it but this episode got me
holy crap
okay
let's get chris up in here wow
okay this got me like really
i want to see who played
now go back
who
who played the voice wow
christine was rachel mcadams she's not a
very good voice actress
sorry to say it but she didn't sound
like it at all
how am i supposed to find you chris if
you're not online
hold
holding
wait can you hear me
uh very
very faintly
now can you hear me
i can hear you now holy crap okay this
this one got me into it
oh did it now this one got me into it uh
yeah um
i thought this was a i thought this was
amazing it was uh
fantastic i heard it here first guys
amazing fantastic
uh i mean i think so i uh
yeah this this one brought me back into
it uh i like how the universe just kind
of goes away at the end like it's a it's
a story about it actually yeah it
actually happened and i was just i was
thinking i was like is this going to be
destroyed like oh my gosh
yeah no that was kind of cool how it
ended like that yeah
really enjoyed that
that was uh
yeah movie world where are my white
hairs uh i've dyed my hair a lot in the
past
it's really an understatement because i
tried to get it a certain color but you
have to like bleach your hair a lot to
get to it
and it's really bad for your hair and i
don't want to like damage it so right
now it you can't tell but it's i guess
you can kind of tell it's blue it's like
black and blue
uh
ammo oreo it's sad doctor strange your
favorite character it is sad but wasn't
that such a cool episode all right guys
let's let's get it going in the chat
already
what are we rating this episode i'm see
i see two ten out of ten so far you
heard the man let's see two ten out of
ten so far
night levi you guys heard the man give
me your ratings
this might be the best episode of the
series um
it might i think it i i i
i
there's what
six more or five more i think five more
i think there's gonna be ten but then
there were nine but then yeah there
still might be ten but who knows
i'm getting ten out of ten nine out of
ten ten out of ten i'm getting nothing
but nines and ten oh there's
seven from whey metal oh 20 out of 20.
i've gotten oh there's a 2 out of 10 wow
i didn't like that
i got a point zero zero zero one out of
ten well 15 out of ten
nine out of ten eight ten out of ten
four i'm getting a lot of tens and nines
there's there's some eights in there i
definitely think it was the best high
and some really low
yeah most of mine are like insanely high
um i think by far it was the best
episode
i think it's the best episode we got so
far
it's my second favorite so far was your
first cha-cha second episode
i actually i just had a lot of fun
watching that this was interesting i
think i just had more fun i had more fun
sure it makes sense i think the story i
think story-wise this was the best
metal says there's something missing
from the show for me i don't know what
it is the show is a whole or the
specific it's the fact that it's
animated for me is it right it takes it
away from me and makes it seem less
even though they've said that it's it
you know it is canon to the mcu the fact
that it's animated for me kind of takes
it away a little bit but uh but this
this episode
changed my mind because i thought
i thought the premise for it i thought
the story was really really good
and
him you know going to like an ancient
lost city
and i just saw alex drop your computer
um
and
absorbing all the stuff then two doctor
stranges and
it actually like the universe actually
ending
like i don't know i like it i think it
was really good it got me more into it
because uh
i'm not gonna lie i wasn't i wasn't that
i wasn't that into it at first
but
this changed my mind i guess
so this was uh
best one best one for me best one for me
there you go there you go i definitely
think this is more of the direction
they're trying to
to place these shows you know i think
the first one and the third one were a
little bit kind of like repetitive and
slow okay it's like the same storyline
with a couple changes to it whereas the
second and the fourth one especially
this one we're just completely different
blown out of the water what if and
that's what makes it fun for me
yeah
i probably agree with that um
i think it's cool what they're trying to
do
but to me i think this is i think this
is where they nailed it i don't know i
feel like
like the first episode was good but to
me it was pretty much the same thing
right captain america i'll be honest i
think the first episode was boring
i think i think it was really cool to
see the animation for the first time um
that's that's true i think they chose a
good first episode like a good job yeah
yeah it got it got started off like
really well with the animation and stuff
like that um
the second episode was a really cool
story and it hits harder because
chadwick
um it was cool to see thanos as a good
guy a lot of the bad guys as good guys
i think also there were just a ton of
characters right right there were so
many characters that helped a lot as
well everything with wakanda you know
all of the ravagers all of you know
thanos and the black order and and
everything like that it was just really
cool to see um and then one condo and
everything like that and then
um i wait a second
i think number two actually resulted in
the destruction of that universe as well
because ego would go on to absorb
star-lord
he would have zero help whatsoever and
everything gets yeah
yeah that's very possible too yeah
but uh you know that that universe isn't
gonna connect to anything
well that's what i was thinking too i
was like wow this is gonna start to
connect to other things but then it
ended so i was like oh maybe not i think
it was really cool
that he acknowledged the watcher and the
watcher was like what's up nah i'm not i
can't do it
you see what's going on right now i
can't do it like you know what i mean
like he actually
let let the
universe get destroyed
yeah and you know that's the cool and
fun thing about these never-ending
timelines because you have to think a
good majority of them
you know even if it was live action mcu
and we're exploring all these timelines
a lot of them are probably apocalyptic
somebody did something wrong the whole
thing grew up well how many times can
the avengers actually save the day well
that's why the tva was a thing right
oh exactly right that's why the tv
that's why kang
was right like i have to do this or
you know there's a multiverse of war
plus destructions
of universes right i mean that that's
that's what happens right
that just that's just like
it goes to show
that kang really isn't the only threat
like universes have their own threats
without kang right they have evil doctor
strange right they have other things
they have you know there's universes
where really loki are is you know
loki supreme right
because the universe is where iron man
just remained a playboy and that was it
right
yeah i mean i i think essentially that
might
be what happened in the first episode
you know probably what happens there um
but you know who knows i i think like
what got me with this episode is where
he kept trying to save her
i really liked that i really and then i
like that they that she was like
it's an absolute point time which i
think is going to be like i think okay
so i had to stop watching it
they say this is canon to the mcu but i
question how
like okay maybe they just ignore the
fact that it's animated and say all
these stories actually happen cool right
but now i think we're actually getting
to the mcu counterpart where she's
talking where the ancient one said an
absolute point in time i think that'll
definitely be
a factor
in the projects coming up yeah 100
and that's the whole idea and i guess
maybe they're just trying to instill
this in our mind with this first season
of what if is literally anything
anywhere can be happening and it is
connected to the mcu maybe not the main
timeline or you know the
the what are they called the sacred
timeline doesn't even exist anymore yeah
but there are other timelines and
they're all just as important or
you know more deadly more powerful more
organized than the one we've been
watching this whole time so it will be
interesting after multiverse of madness
has ended you know talking the live
action movies again where we are left
with the mcu the mcm
and really what direction they decide to
go if this is a prelude to everything
that we're really going to get to see
yeah i have a good question
yeah it's going to be a lot of fun uh
and i think they are
they're they're they're they're getting
us ready like hey
anything it's almost like
right right
so here's a good question from tristan
park i got you
so he says
if christine's death was an absolute
point why didn't it happen in the main
timeline
because the main timeline had a
different absolute point that absolute
point was strange losing his fingers
right not being able to use his fingers
so
the diff here's here's what i'll explain
that that'll help you
so it was an absolute point
but the absolute point was supposed to
lead doctor strange to becoming master
of the mystic arts and then like not
trying to bring her back
obviously him trying to undo that
absolute point ended in the destruction
of the universe right so remember what
if takes us into another universe it
takes us down another timeline so in the
main timeline the absolute point is his
fingers and this timeline that veered
it's him losing christine and that's a
different absolute point and
unfortunately he tried he did undo the
absolute point which ended in the
destruction of his timeline you know
what i don't understand why couldn't he
even just killed her then
that was what i thought i had i was like
as everything's like collapsing i'm like
just kill her just kill her now like
it'll obviously undo everything and i
thought that was what's going to happen
and i'm actually glad it didn't happen
no i thought it was cool that it ended
and just yeah strange i think in a
circle and nothing around him well then
and then just destroyed yeah i think
yeah i think that was a cool way to end
it um
this is the best for me so far
super chat from jake
says
i love you kristen hey is that jake
hedge three exclamation marks yeah
there's jake
he's showing a lot of love
a lot of love tonight
cut off her head mr anderson i know what
mr anderson would do kill it with fire
kill it with fire it was cool it was
also cool how he absorbed everything i
also love how that was a fun sequence
when you're watching to do all that yeah
i are they prepping us for schuma goris
like they showed i'm going to say it was
schumacher
yeah i bet we see it again i'm going to
say maybe
i'm going to say maybe in multiverse of
madness we see some schumacher's action
yeah yeah yeah
so
if if this is what's to come
from
the rest of the
the rest of the episode uh i'm done
i can i can get more into it now um well
i i like the crazy far out there dark
not even necessarily dark but that's
just one of the adjectives like
just absolutely nutty scenarios that we
haven't seen anything of yeah not
slightly altered like oh what if this
person was captain america instead as
cool as that isn't as cool as that
character is i prefer the just way out
there
what if not like the what kind of
that's a good point
if you're going to do it like really
show us something let's go with it and
they did in this episode and honestly
risk reward
it was there was really cool it was it
was crazy
hey it's mary jay welcome um
yeah the first one was kind of like it
kind of changed
and then the second one was cool that
actually did change a lot i mean
essentially it
it changed everything no infinity war
end game no thanos blah blah blah blah
i don't even remember we don't even know
we don't really know the repercussions
of the third episode yet because
it ends with captain marvel showing up
right i mean right so we don't even know
there but this one's a pretty this one's
a pretty big one oh i have a super chat
what if version doctor strange first mcu
doctor strange uh
i actually think we saw that todd andrew
and thanks for the super chat i actually
think that's what we saw at the end
uh i think the normal doctor strange
that didn't you know go back and try to
see i think that's mcu version
granted he hasn't been through
everything like infinity war and all
that stuff
but i think this version overpowers mcu
version and maybe
this version becomes a type of mc
version eventually right and multiverse
amanda i i mean
from what i've heard everything really
like
like multiverse of madness really does
sound like it's gonna be just a crazy
movie
like like like really like everything
i've ever whatever's a man crazy right
everything i've heard about it like
people are saying like literally the
word
bonkers
that's probably not even strong enough
like insiders are saying that and i'm
sitting there like sweet
i want to know
um i want to recognize something that
somebody in your chat ash says
he renamed the the episode strange eats
the marvel universe yeah that's
essentially i don't see that that's
pretty good that's pretty funny it's a
little higher up i saw it and i was just
waiting for it oh i see it ash hole
oh i get it
hey can we also recognize warren only 2
000 away from 800 000 subscribers
close
very very close very close can't we hit
the ground can we hit a million well
within four years of doing youtube
a little hype in the chat for warren
guys a little hype in the chat for
warren he he
yeah i
you know
where was it i just saw it
rather episode was devastating i agree
i
not only like in the literal sense that
the whole universe was destroyed but
i really i don't know why i liked it so
much i guess i just like the
storytelling i really liked how he
couldn't bring her back
how
and then how they explained it like this
is the absolute point
you lose yeah right like you have to be
dr strange
sorcerer supreme like you have to go on
to find the mystic arts and this is the
event that leads you there and if this
event does not happen the universe gets
destroyed
because eventually drama comes and all
the stuff will block the universe is
going to get destroyed either way right
so
this has to happen
and it's just like
i like that like the whole you can't
change the past thing and i like that
like no matter what
no matter which different way he tried
to save her it didn't work like he just
left her there and there was like an
explosion and it killed her right they
went to go get pizza a guy walked in and
shot her for whatever reason all right
yeah right i'm gonna walk in and just
shoot you like what okay uh but
yeah it is similar
what
i was just considering getting a lot of
love from my chat
super chat from jake this is hyper
warren
[Laughter]
mafia is it similar to wanda trying to
bring vision back
similar yes in a way that like visions
and android but in a way that he was
kind of brought to life and given a soul
by ai and the
mind stone
but i didn't
i think that could bring vision back i
think they could bring vision back is
the thing
i don't think it's
an absolute point in time that you can't
reverse bring a vision back i think i
think vision can come back
i'm super excited for vision becomes the
infinity gauntlet episode
is that what that is
i don't know if that's what it's called
i think it's he becomes ultron but he
gets all the infinity stones in the in
the post it looks like that's a ton of
them so i'm all right
i'm like i was literally imagining
vision as a glove that's why i was like
i'm not following i'm like ultron turns
him into a glove and then yeah no i
think it's like he becomes ultron and he
harnesses the infinity stones
essentially yeah but i think he becomes
the infinity gauntlet sounds like
somebody asked a question to the
episodes that did strange
survive that little bubble um i don't
believe so i think the entire universe
collapsed warren what do you think
say it again
did strange survive that little no yeah
thought you said i think the entire
branch just completely collapsed and the
watcher came in and went
um
you're dead everybody take the l yeah
yeah did a little fortnite dance on him
and then dipped yeah yeah your trash
your trash kid
you're trash
i do like how the watcher was
acknowledged and i like how he's like i
read about you and since your presence
and even before that's just the level of
power that strange got to and it's
really cool that it's like yeah he felt
his presence he's like i read about you
know who i i know who you are and
help us and he's like not fam
snapped away of the super chat tell
chris i got you over on your side too
love you chris
there you go
i don't know what you're doing he's
hiding his words
he's hiding his words like this so you
can't hear anything he's chris is being
sneaky
and he's muted so i can't hear him like
a little i said that's the guy from
fortnite no he's a member on my stream
he's my first ever member stopped away
yeah first ever member well he'd be up
in her
well good for you he's a great guy to
have
yeah heck you're not that guy jake
you're not that guy pal
that's a little rude
no he's saying that's what the watcher
said oh yeah i mean you're not that guy
pal you're trash kid
you're trash
if i were the watcher i'd be dropping
some memes on strange right then i'm
just telling you what he was a lot more
professional than i would have been
it's funny that like it's funny that he
appeared and talked to him though
because he's like i can't interfere and
it's not inter it's like uh
it's like loki is saying that you can do
whatever you want right before a
cataclysmic event right it doesn't
matter that's pretty much what he just
did right like that's why he was i'm not
interfering you're about to be done four
seconds yeah you're about to die the
whole universe is about to you know
cease to exist and it's your fault buddy
you uh you shouldn't have done that the
trash kid
so
well
i mean
my big my big sadness about it is it's
hard to speculate about future stuff
because it kind of happens that it ends
even if they connect somebody was just
saying brandon over here was just saying
i missed the loki discussions because
those were a little bit more in depth
than talking about you know how does
this connect to the movies and
everything going on which we don't
really get with these well whoever is
fun to speculate about the the
multiverse coming down in the future
well whoever said it in the beginning
it's missing something that's what it's
missing is that's what it's missing the
big okay so loki did this and what's
going to happen next and where's the
connection it doesn't really have that
there there aren't exactly repercussions
it's the thing right there's no
connectivity to it and even though they
say it's canon
that doesn't necessarily mean it really
affects much right right right so that's
that's kind of the whole thing and in
the in the way that we really don't know
how it will
affect everything
so that's what it's missing but
it's fun
it was a very fun episode it was pretty
crazy to watch like i didn't obviously i
don't think you did but i definitely
didn't see this one early um
so when it started and she just kept
dying over and over and over again i was
like oh
well okay
yeah
you went with that direction
i like it and it was um
i think this was a a little sneak peek
of uh multiverse of madness
i think i hope i hope something like
that if it's a little idea it it had a
little horror to it um
it had a little horror to it you know
and i and i think that's
i
i think that's a little glimpse of
multiverse of madness and i kind of hope
it is because
i really like the
dark art side of it right
like
the magic that they shouldn't be doing
possessing
uh
you know these beans looked like he even
possessed our
eight nightmare did you see that yeah i
did see that i thought that was
nightmare
it it definitely the way he grabbed the
other strange at the end too looked like
it was like a nightmare thing yeah
yeah for sure for sure for sure
super fun i mean it was a fun episode i
think they're gonna get more fun as well
we have other really cool stuff zombies
which i know a lot of you guys out there
extremely excited for it's all i ever
see in my comments yeah lot of people
it's coming it's coming it's coming and
it's gonna be fun uh hopefully
uh
the vision episode's gonna be fun the
i guess the guardian of the avengers
galaxy is gonna be a fun one so a lot of
fun stuff coming
yeah i think
i think
i hope
it gets better from here
i was gonna say i think it's gonna get
better i hope it gets better from here
um we do have the zombie episode like
everyone's talking about right i mean
yeah i mean we have that coming up so
um
i think i think it's gonna be good i
think i think a lot of good stuff is
gonna happen so
may i see
a few people have mentioned mephisto um
maybe he did i'll have to go slow it
down and look maybe absorb mephisto who
knows i think mephisto is probably a
little bit too powerful for that i don't
know if doctor strange could just
summon mephisto against his will
but this is well that's a big question
right could you just summon my crew can
you just summon me i'm sure if you
looked in the mirror and said his name
three times he'd
pop up yeah right let's try that maybe
we can ask him where he's been yeah
right when are you popping up when are
you showing up in the mcu and can you
please leave now are you doctor strange
goodbye
yeah
so it was a good episode uh best for me
so far i think um
i think this will bring a lot of people
into it just like me like i yeah i hope
so i hope that's the case yeah uh
because we're getting more we're getting
to season two
and it's gonna have some phase four
characters in it maybe some shang qi
action or some
new um
captain america sorry i'm blinked ah
yeah um
a lot of excited stuff coming
so as you guys can see i'm very tired
and we're gonna have to do some work
for the trailer um i'm going to do a
breakdown
it's probably going to come tomorrow
afternoon
because again yeah it's 2 a.m for me
uh
do you have a funny
a
funny little
spiderman invitational video
i mean i do talk about a leak but i also
talk about
like a funny leak
or a funny leak it is funny but the leak
part is air quotes not not the funny
part
so i'm
i think people will get a kick out of it
it's a quick little video tomorrow just
to keep you all occupied until i get my
breakdown out so
look out for that in the morning
uh thanks rossi uh
thanks
v
min x l y z z v
thank you uh take it everybody
thank you everybody for stopping by the
stream today yeah thank you everybody
that was all fun it was a good one it
was very fun it was very fun it was very
fun make sure to subscribe to mr beast
oh wait no
cosmic wonder
mr beast has enough subscribers
[Laughter]
the wave will never stop
that dude knows business i do need to
get the ancient one to uh
to split to split me that sounds wrong
to split me in half i do need to get the
warrant yeah
late night
yeah right i uh i do need to get the
ancient one to come
head how do i if it sounds weird
[Music]
yeah
yeah
exactly i agree wholeheartedly a lot of
people do what
i don't know
whatever you were trying to say
oh i'm like what are you watching here
um
yeah um
it
i don't even know uh it's fun it's a lot
of fun i like uh
i like doing these live streams it's fun
guys if you haven't jumped over to
chris's channel cosmic culture be sure
to go yeah i can see you type that link
in there
oh no mr anderson already did it he beat
you to it he yeah i was trying to beat
him because i knew as soon as he said he
was going to post somebody
split me into another awesome cosmic
there you go
thank you uh guys if you haven't
subscribed to chris
do so if you enjoy
marvel dc star wars movies in general
that's what he talks about on his
channel
uh same as me does it every day check
him out and uh we'll be back here next
week same time same place since it's you
know a virtual place and we can all meet
here
and uh
i i saw a lot of ten out of tens but
uh when this uh ends go ahead and
comment what you rated it in the
comments after the live stream ends
though
uh one out of ten what do you think
thank you everybody who stopped by thank
you to everybody who
chatted who super chatted greatly
appreciate that support helping the
channel and even if you're just watching
in the background having a good time
appreciate that as well um thank you to
mr anderson for being an awesome mod
again and as always i love you all i'll
see you next